in film red the corose state that Shanks
is a member of the figure land family
one of the most prominent royal
bloodlines among the celestial dragons
through extra material that was released
with the movie we learned when exactly
Shanks became a member of Roger's crew
when Shanks was just a one-year-old baby
he was found by Roger inside a treasure
chest on God Valley we know that
prominent Celestial dragons were present
on God Valley at that time and it was
later confirmed that the supreme
commander of the Gods Knights Elite
Royal Guards is named Saint Garling
figurland this Garling figure land is
also known as the champion of God Valley
which means that he was almost certainly
present during the god Valley incident
since Shanks is a member of the figure
land family and since we know he was
found by Roger on God Valley he has to
be related to Garling in fact Garling
could be shanks's father subscribe to
anime uproar right now